i'm carly are you ready
okay
now all hands in on three one two three
he probably should have gone over it
before i'm in a hot
hot relationship wait with who what a
rude question
did you want icarly to be the most
successful web series in history or did
you want it to just be like a massive
failure i mean probably the most
successful web series in history don't
we're going out
are those unicorn pajamas
did you see he's dabbing dale
he would work himself up and flail
around like a bird with another bird up
its ass
we've been waiting years for you two to
get together
steamy i get a room
what the hell are you wearing my
custom-made spencer shay salsa slacks
[Music]
this party looks like a home run to me
this is the groovy smoothie it sure is
happy birthday oh my reese witherspoon
whoever said harper couldn't pull this
off was seriously misguided
hey friends
i will not choose violence
make it sound cooler it'd be hard to
make it sound dumber i could never do
this show without you i raised the best
woman i know
my sister
[Music]
it begins i thought it already began oh
it's begun
[Music]
you